bonjour frédéric bhérer bonjour monsieur
le temps bonjour aux techniciens de
martinique première qui oeuvrent pour
diffuser cette émission et bonjour
surtout aux auditrices et auditeurs de
martinique 1ère premier secrétaire de la
fédération socialiste de martinique
merci d'être avec nous au moment où
l'ouragan matthew continue de frapper la
cara et théâtre de désolation
aujourd'hui pour cuba république
dominicaine haïti la jamaïque est en ce
moment même les bahamas les politiques
frédéric bhérer les dirigeants
politiques les leaders de formations
porte t-il assez le message de la
prévention du risque majeur dans un pays
comme le nôtre la martinique
on n'a jamais trop fait beaucoup de
choses sont faites depuis un certain
temps en ce sens mais on n'a jamais trop
fait il faut continuer ce travail en
afrique à 6 aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est
un peu ce que sont en train de bouder un
bon on peut on peut épiloguer là-dessus
est ce qu'on fait un c'est ce qu'ont
fait pas assez
ce qu'un jeu on reconnaît moi c'est que
beaucoup de belles choses en ce sens
sont faites en matière de prévention il
faut continuer il faut intensifier
maintenant il y à aussi sur la
projection qu'il faut faire en matière
d'urbanisme notamment et je sais de quoi
je parle
il faut préparer les peaux population à
ces risques là parce que d'après les
spécialistes il n'y vont pas en
négociant les risques sont là et sans
faire le jeu de mots ils risquent de
regret c'est que ce ce discours n'est
pas très courant n'est pas très commun
chez les leaders actuels c'est on entend
beaucoup plus de bruit des concurrents
sur autre chose
c'est vrai je trouve cela déplorable
c'est malheureux c'est malheureux pour
l'instant des hommes et des femmes
politiques qu'ils soient aux commandes
ou pas c'est déplorable pour nous tous
mais je ne désespère pas que tout ça
s'arrête très bientôt
parce que les uns les autres on est élu
pour diriger les affaires du pays et
pour le mieux-être des martiniquais pour
le développement du pays et je crois que
chaque
un coeur de développer le pays je pense
que ce soit comme vous dites décor du
mouvement il faut pas qu'il continue je
crois qu'il faut que ce cercle
on est dans nos rédactions s'en étonne
c'est le constat que nous faisons nous
avons des leaders qui attendent d'être
sollicités pour dire quelque chose pour
prendre position pour un décès est
encore pour des déclarations style
identitaire l'histoire la colonisation
il faut quand même attendre plusieurs
jours pour que les mots sortent du bois
oui que qu'est ce qu'on peut vous dire
là dessus je je peux qu on aimerait que
nous que nos politiques prennent
position sur davantage de choses à des
guides et éclairer les leaders justement
si si je crois que il ya des hommes et
des femmes qui prennent des positions
quand il le faut
peut-être que en tant que journaliste
vous trouvez que ce n'est pas suffisant
en tout cas en ce qui nous concerne à la
fsm nous pour une opposition très tôt
sur les gants les gonds sujet les grands
mots nous donnons très régulièrement
notre opinion notre vision des choses
sans personne ne peut nous le rouge et
les socialistes devront faire preuve
d'imagination au moment où ou où va
arriver très rapidement cette campagne
pour la primaire dans votre camp on
rappelle que le scrutin aura lieu les 22
et 29 janvier prochains
tout récemment votre famille politique a
défini les règles du jeu autour d'une
belle alliance populaire
pourtant sans le parti communiste sans
europe ecologie les verts sans le prg et
les socialistes ose parler quand même de
rassemblement et bien je vous remercie
cette introduction si nous avons fait la
belle alliance populaire soit 105 le
titre c'est bien parce que ses hôtes et
que nous avons sans cesse depuis environ
deux ans appelés à ce rassemblement
on ne l'ont pas accepté la main tendue
et l'ont fait savoir de manière
virulente bien bien à bien des reprises
et tout récemment comme nous l'avons et
c est bien
nous avons créé ce qu'on appelle c'est
l'idée vient de quelques ténors du parti
quelques intellectuels surtout qu'ils
ont fait la proposition de créer sept de
l'alliance populaire qui a un
rassemblement il ya quelques temps un
lundi le des leaders socialistes disait
mais il y aura-t-il une primaire je veux
bien être candidat mais lurati d'une
primaire vous savez il y en a qui
fonctionnent avec des chimères et qui
sont qui veulent aussi des vols aussi
que les choses se fassent avant l'heure
nous sommes en politique il faut bien
souvent rencontre les uns les autres ça
prend du temps discuter négocier chacun
assez égaux chacun a ses stratégies et
il faut l'accepter
ça prend du temps mais vous constaterez
que nous sommes dans les temps sans
faire de jeu de mots
en 2011 nous avons organisé les
primaires si je me souviens bien
au mois d'octobre là nous organisons les
primaires à haut risque de me tromper me
sens bien c'est un mois d'octobre et
nous organiser les primaires les 22 et
29 janvier comme vous dites nous sommes
dans les temps l'élection ça fait
quelques semaines mois après alors en
martinique qui sera concerné dans dans
les familles politiques que nous
connaissons ici la fsm forcément la
fédération socialiste de martinique mais
le ppm et que c'est moi pas je pose la
question pourquoi pas nous n'avons ni
absolument rien vous voulez que je le
répète un second jeudi le 23 décembre
2015 et que je n'ai de cesse de répéter
nous n'avons d'histoire avec qui que ce
soit ou alors contre qui que ce soit
puisque nous avons les et vous avez les
moyens en martinique et frédéric bhérer
de de fer d'organiser cette
cette primaire socialiste nous l'avons
fait en 2011
c'était pas plus évident sûr qu'on a
l'impression que la fsm perd ses troupes
et je ne comprends pas qu est ce qui
vous fait dire ça c'est vrai la parodie
moi tout simplement à paroles mundi et
auto mais c'est plus sérieusement
faudrait qu'ils libèreraient
reconnaissez que le discours du parti
socialiste en martinique ça a du mal à
passer regarder une preuve lorsque
patrick et kader ministre des sports
vient ici lorsque dernièrement monsieur
kacem ministre de l'intérieur vient zac
même cette pro courant mais c'est pas
nous seuls les macbook ne savent même
pas la fête guadeloupe automne alors
qu'il n'y ait plus et là il faut savoir
si vous voulez quand vous avez une tête
parce que les martiniquais écoute la
veille le soit la veille du jour où il
arrivait en guadeloupe mais jean moulin
redouter un appel pour me demander où
est le mini c'est est ce qu'il vient
qu'à l'heure où ira-t-il et des choses
comme ça c'est la même chose dans votre
famille on parle de rassemblement
noja pons et j'ai dénoncé cela récemment
et avec force et j'ai entendu d'ailleurs
au niveau du parti je crois la couenne
exactement que ce n'est pas sérieux de
la part de ces deux grandes
personnalités du gouvernement de venir
ici sans que la fsm soit officiellement
mise au courant absolument et je suis
dans les 15 jours d'itt à j'y suis allé
bien plus loin que ça je n'ai pas
demandé simplement qu'on soit informé
mais qu'il y ait un temps qu'ils soient
réservées pour une rencontre avec nous
c'est possible parce que manuel valls du
temps où il était ministre de
l'intérieur il a passé plus d'une heure
avec nous il ya de moins en moins de
france il me l'a fait
la mini cela la toute puissante
démissionnaire la mieux pour lanvin la
faire plusieurs reprises et puis donne
aussi le ministre ecker du budget l'a
fait donc c'est possible
simplement je crois savoir ce qui se
passe il y à des membres de cabinet qui
font leurs petites affaires
et puis qui au dernier moment dans nos
programmes au ministre et le ministre
ont copié que peut-il faire et puis elle
leur demande de faire de faire un
programme pour eux mais ça va rentrer
dans l'ordre
ça rentre dans l'aude tarder alors oui
j'ai été entendu vous n'allez cas vous
n'avez qu'à aller sur les réseaux
sociaux et voir les réactions des
ministres et même d'autres ministres et
même des dirigeants du parti les choses
entrent dans leur jeu vous à saint parce
que chacun a compris que la base
militaire c'est un qui est important on
veut refaire à revenir
fédérer vous parlez de la primaire de la
campagne mais merci laventie ce matin
dans son caddie leçon je n'ai vraiment
pas le temps de vous déclinez quelques
dates de notre val demi comme une
seconde
eh bien il faut savoir que
l'installation de la haute autorité des
primaires se fera le 5 octobre le dépôt
des candidatures se fera du 1er au 15
décembre 2016 merci merci fred à gré